buongiorno questi diciotto minuti per
riuscire a parlare di uno stato senza
prigioni sono veramente pochi mi sento
quasi un po imprigionato devo dire nel
tempo e perché è un tema è un tema che
richiederebbe una riflessione profonda e
soprattutto molto molto molto prolungata
io credo che si debba partire comunque
per cercare di riuscire a dare un senso
il significato a identificare bene
questa parola che cos'è un carcere che
cos'è un carcere perché se vogliamo
riflettere un po sulla possibilità di
vedere una comunità nella quale non
esiste un carcere per prima cosa
dobbiamo riuscire a capire bene che
cos'è un carcere
c'è la parola stessa deriva dal latino
dall'idea delle sbarre
il carcere quindi è caratterizzato in
primo luogo dalle sparse in italia e in
carcere le persone stanno chiuse in
celle che hanno mediamente la dimensione
di circa po meno di 12 metri quadri non
uno soltanto in dodici metri quadri ma
più persone in dodici metri quadri in
periodi di crisi cioè quando c'è
sovraffollamento
le persone sono magari 6 7 8
12 metri quadri meno di 12 metri quadri
nelle quali insistono anche le bambine a
castello e tutto quello che può servire
alle persone che ci abitano
compreso una specie di bugigattolo in
cui c'è una turca o un vate è un
lavandino nel quale si fa anche da
mangiare e le persone in questo carcere
stanno normalmente ci sono delle
eccezioni ma sono rare stanno per
22 ore al giorno se togliamo le ore
d'aria per tutto il resto stanno nella
cella chiusa a chiave insieme ad altre
tre quattro cinque sei persone e chi sta
dentro queste celle può vedere i propri
familiari soltanto
per complessive sei ore al mese
questo è il carcere in italia
gabbie
persone chiuse per un tempo così
definito nelle condizioni che vi dicevo
allora se questo è un carcere
esistono delle condizioni in cui una
persona può subire una limitazione della
libertà personale in modo completamente
diverso
adesso forse non ci sono quasi più ma
quando andavo io alle media liceo io per
fortuna mia non ci sono mai stato
c'erano i colleghi ei ragazzi che
vivevano in un collegio
potevano circolare soltanto nell'ambito
del collegio poi tornavano magari a casa
il sabato e la domenica però durante la
settimana erano anche loro limitati
nella possibilità di muoversi oltre una
determinata struttura
ecco il collegio non è un carcere per
intenderci e allora quando noi parliamo
quando io mi riferisco immagino uno
stato senza carcere non escludo che
possa esistere la possibilità di tenere
delle persone quando le persone sono
pericolose ed esclusivamente quando le
persone sono pericolose in un posto in
cui hanno dei confini
ma questo non è più un carcere nel
momento in cui questa situazione non è
una situazione
della quale le persone vivono in una
limitazione come quella che vi dicevo
prima
non è un carcere quando le persone
appostano per esempio
liberamente muoversi nell'ambito di
quella struttura
uscendo dalla cella uscendo dalla camera
perché non è più una cella
potendo passeggiare il made in
quell'ambito e così via
nel carcere
normalmente non si lavora
credo che sia all 87 per cento più o
meno dei detenuti che in italia non
lavorano
passano infatti la grandissima parte
della giornata
chiusi nelle loro celle 22 euro al
giorno
a che cosa serve il carcere a che cosa
dovrebbe servire il carcere per tutti
noi
ma io credo che il collegamento primo
immediato diretto sia con la sicurezza
il carcere serve a dare sicurezza alle
persone che sono fuori perché serve a
dare sicurezza non perché le persone che
hanno commesso qualcosa di dannoso nei
confronti degli altri che hanno commesso
un reato un crimine ci restano per tutta
la vita perché sarebbe anche soltanto
assurdo pensare che chi ha commesso un
reato un furto per esempio devo passare
tutta la vita in carcere
sabbia diritto a criminogeno questo
perché se tutte le persone che hanno
commesso un reato dovessero passare la
loro vita in carcere ad ora non ci
sarebbero differenze
il furto è priverebbe all'omicidio
in carcere ci si sta per un tempo
limitato
generalmente purtroppo in italia io dico
purtroppo esiste ancora l'ergastolo
salvo i casi di a castro ci si sta per
un tempo limitato per quel tempo
limitato la sicurezza è garantita nei
confronti di quella singola persona dal
fatto che questa persona è esclusa dai
rapporti con tutte le altre persone e
però questo vale per un tempo limitato
la sicurezza dipende si dice da che cosa
ed alla capacità di
deterrenza che il carcere svolge nei
confronti della persona che viene
incarcerata e di tutti gli altri che
vedono che se qualcuno commette un reato
viene messo in prigione
ecco io credo che questo sia
questa sia una convinzione
completamente sbagliata in effetti il
carcere non serve a svolgere una
attività di differenza e quindi a
prevenire comportamenti
devianti comportamenti che possono
danneggiare gli altri
perché ve lo dico perché ci sono i
numeri a testimoniarlo sa dimostrarlo
il 69 per cento delle persone che escono
oggi dal carcere commettono nuovi
alleati
e vuol dire che lo strumento è uno
strumento che non va bene che non serve
aumentare la nostra sicurezza
pensate ci sono degli strumenti diversi
che invece garantiscono in misura
notevolmente maggiore però lasciamo
perdere per il momento ci arriveremo
forse se questo
perché io davanti i cronometri non voi
non lo vedete mancano dieci minuti e 39
anzi 38 37 36 secondi
vediamo se riusciremo ad arrivarci e
seguiamo il filo il 69 per cento delle
persone che esce dal carcere come te
nuovi enti il che vuol dire che
evidentemente
il carcere non ha una efficacia
deterrente nemmeno nei confronti delle
persone che ci sono state
figurarsi nei confronti degli altri che
non hanno nemmeno provato questa
incredibile per la privazione della
libertà personale
la quale così abbassando potremmo
chiederci ma è in coerenza con la nostra
costituzione
cioè quel che vi ho descritto prima del
carcere e in coerenza con l'articolo 27
della costituzione che dice che la pena
deve tendere alla rieducazione del
condannato
e non può consistere in trattamenti
contrari al senso di umanità
ma io vi pregherei di provare a
immaginarli ciascuno di noi si immagini
per conto suo di rimanere
giustamente ingiustamente non importa
provare a
immaginarsi che cosa si sentirebbe
se si fosse messi in quella condizione
ma non pertanto facciamo 6 mesi ciascuno
di noi provi a sentire
simulando ovviamente le proprie
sensazioni dopo aver passato sei mesi
insieme ad altre quattro cinque sei
persone in dodici metri quadri con il
bugigattolo lì di fianco potendo
incontrare vedere per sei ore al mese
tutti i suoi parenti uscirebbe
riconciliato con il resto della società
o non gli verrebbe voglia di fargliela
pagare
il carcere è un luogo di riconciliazione
o è un luogo nel quale si coltiva
questo desiderio di rivincita
questa sensazione di essere stati
oppressi e di voler riprendersi
danneggiando gli altri un posto
fatta questa premessa ma è possibile
qualche cosa di diverso
qualche cosa di diverso esiste
ci sono dei paesi per esempio la
norvegia in cui ci sono delle carceri ci
sono delle carceri che secondo il nostro
metro non dovrebbero neanche chiamarsi
carceri
perché
si tratta di appartamenti si tratta di
appartamenti nei quali le persone
possono entrare e uscire
avendo soltanto il limite del
perimetro di quella luogo in cui stanno
come starebbero dei ragazzi che studiano
in un collegio ci sono delle cose simili
e chi è posto in quelle condizioni
beh non passa il tracciato sul proprio
letto la giornata
studia o lavora
e cioe svolge un'attività che è tesa al
reinserimento della persona
io credo che il maggior problema che
riguarda chi si trova in carcere sia
proprio quello relativo alla capacità di
assumersi responsabilità e cioè di
rispondere agli altri che vuol dire di
stare insieme agli altri di rispettare
le regole che ci siamo dati
con il contributo più o meno
incisivo di ciascuno di noi per vivere
insieme nel modo più dignitoso possibile
ma voi pensate che una
necessità del genere l'acquisizione
della responsabilità possa essere
soddisfatta
attraverso un regime che impedisce il
lavoro era in edifici dello studio
e non c'è soltanto quello che vi dicevo
no che queste queste strutture
norvegia è così non esistono soltanto
queste strutture esistono anche dei
sistemi dei mezzi che in italia sono chi
lo sa perché assolutamente sconosciuti
uno di questi è costituito dalla
giustizia riparativa
e noi non sappiamo neanche che cosa
voglia dire la parola nonostante che in
europa non soltanto se ne parli ma se ne
pratichi da una sessantina d'anni se mi
ricordo bene risale al 1964
l'inizio di questa sperimentazione che
poi è diventata normativa
in belgio in germania in austria
ma non soltanto in europa un po da tutte
le parti del mondo negli stati uniti in
canada in nuova zelanda in australia è
che cosa si fa
e in primo luogo si si tiene conto delle
vittime
il nostro sistema
la vittima la disconosce completamente
come se la vittima non esistesse
addirittura per poter ottenere il
risarcimento del danno la vittima deve
prendersi un avvocato costituirsi in
giudizio
partecipare se non venderà in iniziativa
la vittima io credo che sia in qualche
modo
ed è un pochino danneggiata dal sistema
pensate cosa succede a una ragazza che
abbia subito una violenza
che deve andare a far la denuncia
raccontare tutto nei minimi particolari
e ai carabinieri o alla polizia e poi
viene richiamata dal pubblico ministero
e deve rivivere il dolore di quello che
ha subito un'altra volta e poi davanti
al giudice in contraddittorio con il
difensore di chi l'ha aggredita che fa
di tutto per screditarla
e questo quello che riserva alla vittima
e il nostro sistema
ma riserva qualche cosa ebbe molto meno
traumatico ma per lo meno fastidioso
anche a chi subito un furto
e devia dalla la denuncia e poi vai al
processo perché ti chiamano per
confermare che ammesso che sia stato
trovato l'autore più una cosa per la
verità rarissima
ecco invece con il sistema della
giustizia riparativa emessi da una
grande rilievo alla vittima perché la
finalità di questo metodo è quello di
riuscire a riparare per quanto è
possibile la vittima è
contemporaneamente rendere cosciente
il responsabile del male che ha fatto
è un percorso
è un percorso attraverso il quale la
vittima è responsabile vengono portati
ad incontrarsi in modo che luna possa
recuperare il senso della propria
dignità che attraverso il reato è stato
distrutto
peraltro senza essere per questo
distrutto dai sensi di colpa
possa
rendersi conto di quello che ha fatto e
per questo perché se n'è reso conto
evitare di farlo il futuro ecco dicevo
da noi è sconosciuto nonostante che una
decisione quadro del consiglio
dell'unione europea chiedo scusa abbia
reso sostanzialmente obbligatoria
l'introduzione del sistema di giustizia
riparativa in tutti gli stati membri
dell'unione e noi siamo molto lontani
dal concepire una possibilità del genere
e allora io credo che
faremo fatica ad arrivarci
fintanto che la nostra cultura
continuerà il nostro modo di pensare
adesso è così tanto resistente rispetto
alla possibilità di cambiare quella idea
di fondo secondo la quale il male va
retribuito col male
pensate che a rischio abbiamo quello di
confondere il male col bene
se noi pensiamo che il male si supera si
recupera si trasforma infliggendo il
male e allora allora trasformiamo il
male che infliggiamo in vena no perché è
un male che serve a cancellare il male
commesso precedentemente sarà ben male
per chi lo subisce essere messo in una
cella in quelle condizioni che vi dicevo
se noi pensiamo che fare male a una
persona serva
per arrivare al bene e allora non c'è
più differenza tra il bene e il male
entriamo in una confusione assoluta non
abbiamo più punti di riferimento
io credo che
sia necessario approfondire mancano
soltanto 31 secondi altri 30
credo che sia necessario entrarci dentro
credo che sia necessario che ciascuno di
noi si ponga il problema
ma non per un senso di umanità che pure
è
importantissimo
io direi anche per arrivare a centrare
quell'obiettivo
quello di trovare un sistema attraverso
il quale potere ciascuno di noi essere
più sicuro di quanto lo sia adesso